nous recevons Monsieur Olivier Dussac
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion je vous précise que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
du Sénat disponible en vidéo à la
demande
monsieur le ministre le Sénat est saisi
du projet de loi pour le plein emploi
notre commission devrait l'examiner dès
la semaine prochaine mercredi 28 juin
avant son passage en séance prévue du
lundi 10 au jeudi 13 en clôture de
session extraordinaire je précise que le
Sénat est la première assemblée saisie
sur ce projet de loi tandis que chemine
en parallèle à l'Assemblée nationale un
autre texte sur le travail le projet de
loi portant transposition de l'accord
national interprofessionnel relatif au
partage de la valeur au sein de
l'entreprise
que les députés examineront en séance du
26 au 29 juin
peut-être pourrez-vous nous préciser
monsieur le ministre les raisons qui ont
motivé le gouvernement à scindé ces
textes à faire ses parcours croisés
j'en profite pour vous informer monsieur
le ministre que j'ai dit en conférence
des présidents de la semaine dernière
qu'il ne me semblerait pas très opportun
de commencer la session 2023 2024 du
Sénat par l'examen de ce projet de loi
sur la nid en effet c'est l'obligerait
la Commission à adopter son rapport de
sa réunion constitutive
le 5 octobre centre à vos peurs
préparatoires et sans avoir pu entendre
les ministres ni partenaire sociaux
il en a été fait acte à la Conférence
des Présidents monsieur le mini je vais
vous laisser la parole pour un propos
introductif et notre rapporteur Pascal
grenier les autres commissaires qu'il
souhaiteront vous interrogerons par la
suite monsieur ministre à vous merci
beaucoup madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pour répondre à votre
interrogation madame la Présidente
d'abord vous dire que je transmettrai le
message que vous délivrez sur la date
d'examen du texte pourtant transposition
de la Cour nationale
interprofessionnelle par le Sénat vous
savez que ça ne relève pas ma compétence
mais je peux faire le messager de votre
déclaration et de vos intentions pour
cette rentrée du Sénat pour ce qui
concerne le calendrier les modalités
d'examen le Gouvernement a souhaité que
ces deux textes fassent l'objet d'examen
séparés dans la mesure où la cor
nationale interprofessionnelle transpose
relatif au partage de la valeur fait
l'objet d'une transposition nous
souhaitons intégrale et fidèle c'était
le sens de l'engagement pris devant les
partenaires sociaux lorsque j'ai ouvert
cette
au mois de septembre 2022 et la
meilleure façon d'intégrer d'assurer
pardon la transcription intégrale et
fidèle et d'avoir un seul véhicule
législatif et je le dis pour laisser une
matrice et les sénateurs la ligne qui
est celle du gouvernement pour l'examen
de ce texte par l'Assemblée puisque
l'assemblée la adopté en commission
lundi soir et de réserver tous les avis
favorables du gouvernement aux seules
amendements qui ont fait l'objet d'un
assentiment de chacun des sept
partenaires sociaux signataires de la
Corse c'est-à-dire 4 des 5 organisations
syndicales et trois organisations
patronales sur trois nous considérons
que lorsque des amendements ne sont pas
conformes exactement conformes à la ENI
nous conditionnons la vie favorable du
Gouvernement un accord des signataires
pour préserver le consensus jusqu'à la
fin de l'examen et de la mise en oeuvre
de cet accord c'est vraiment cette
raison qui nous a amené à dissocier les
deux sujets par ailleurs le calendrier
d'examen avec ces examens croisés comme
vous l'avez dit mais en réalité que la
que le miroir
d'un agenda parlementaire dans les deux
chambres et d'une modalité
d'organisation du calendrier des travaux
pour en venir à au projet de loi que je
vous présente aujourd'hui relatif au
plein emploi peut-être repartir du
constat que nous avons fait au cours des
derniers mois d'abord un constat positif
dans la mesure où l'économie française a
créé au cours des six dernières années
cinq années et demi si on se réfère à
des bornes électorales un million 700
000 emplois ce qui permet au chômage de
diminuer de 9,5 à 7,1%. et ce qui a par
ailleurs permis notre économie et notre
pays d'afficher un taux d'emploi
supérieur à ceux que nous avons connu
depuis la création de l'indicateurs du
taux d'emploi le taux d'emploi mesure la
fraction de population en emploi entre
15 et 64 ans au sens de l'INSEE et nous
sommes à 68,6% ce qui est le plus
autonome depuis 1975 création de
l'indice c'est aussi le plus haut taux
d'emploi pour les 15 24 ans depuis 1990
et nous avons aussi un record en la
matière pour le taux d'emploi des
seniors la deuxième chose qui est
intéressante et les chiffres de l'année
2022 le montrent c'est que depuis la
toute fin de l'année 2021 pour la
première fois depuis une trentaine
d'années ce qui est quand même beaucoup
les emplois créés lorsqu'on regarde ce
même cet indicateur l'Insee qui concerne
les embauches en contrat de un mois ou
plus d'un mois les emploie créés sont
pour 52% des emplois créant CDI alors
que sur les dix années précédentes nous
étions sur une moyenne de 46 à 47% de
CDI dans les emplois créés ce qui est
plutôt bon signe et ce qui prend le
contre-pied de l'image que l'on se fait
parfois d'un développement massif de
l'auto-entreprise ou
de liens liés de lien direct entre
création d'emplois et promotion de
l'apprentissage malgré ce constat
positif nous gardons un taux de chômage
qui est supérieur à la moyenne
européenne à 7,1% même très largement
supérieur et ce taux de chômage
supérieur à la moyenne europ créer une
situation un peu paradoxale puisqu'il ne
résout rien au contraire les difficultés
de recrutement que les entreprises
rencontrent et se sont environ deux
tiers des PME qui nous disent avoir des
difficultés de recrutement et 60% des
entreprises industrielles qui nous
disent renoncer à des opportunités de
croissance ou de développement pour des
questions liées au recrutement nous
avons cherché à comprendre évidemment
trois causes sont apparues comme
identifiables la première concerne
l'adéquation entre les compétences des
demandeurs d'emploi et les besoins des
entreprises nous essayons d'y répondre
je crois collectivement je pense
notamment à l'action des régions depuis
2018 dans le cadre du plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
nous savons qu'il y a une deuxième
raison qui peut tenir un certain nombre
de règles relatifs au marché du travail
il y en ademnisation d'assurance chômage
et nous considérons que les deux
réformes de 2019 et 2022 apportent des
réponses qui sont satisfaisantes et à
nos yeux suffisantes à ces questions là
et enfin il a une troisième explication
bien sûr qui concerne le fonctionnement
du service public et c'est à ce
fonctionnement du service public de
l'emploi que nous voulons apporter des
réponses avec ce texte ce texte s'appuie
sur une concertation menée par le
haut-commissaire à l'emploi et
l'engagement des entreprises Thibault
à auditionner toutes les parties
prenantes pour faire en sorte d'aboutir
à un rapport qui m'a été remis le 17
avril avec 10 principes que le
gouvernement reprend totalement à son
compte et 99 propositions bien
évidemment de ne reprenons pas les 89
les 99 propositions mais beaucoup sont
utiles et toutes t'enlèvent d'ailleurs
pas du de la loi ni même ni même du
règlement le texte que nous vous
présentons est un texte court avec 11
articles et finalement il y a trois
objectifs principaux à ce texte puis un
quatrième mais qui est porté par mon
collègue Jean-Christophe combe le
premier objectif que nous poursuivons et
d'améliorer la structure et la
gouvernance du service public de
l'emploi avec la transformation de Pôle
emploi en France travail et le maintien
pour Pôle emploi de venir France travail
d'un statut d'opérateur avec en plus un
rôle de coordination de services au
service en tout cas de production au
service des autres acteurs de l'emploi
je pense notamment au système
d'information ou à la construction de
référentiel commun ce n'est pas une
recentralisation je reviendrai sur ce
point puisque l'opérateur France
travaille Pôle Emploi aujourd'hui jouera
demain le rôle de soutien technique
d'animateur opérationnel dans le cadre
du gouvernance très partagée avec les
élus locaux avec les collectivités ce
qui est la principale nouveauté
il y a un certain nombre
d'interrogations qui se font jour et
c'est bien légitime quand on aborde le
sujet du service public de l'emploi
d'abord je tiens à préciser que les
initiatives locales seront évidemment
conservées dans bon nombre de
territoires le réseau France travail
fonctionne déjà par une bonne
coordination des acteurs même si nous
savons que tout ça est très inégal et
c'est assez légitime d'un territoire à
l'autre il n'est pas question de
remettre en cause ce qui marche la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'opérateurs du service
public de l'emploi aujourd'hui qui joue
un rôle fondamental et qui continueront
à le jouer je pense en particulier aux
missions locales qui interviennent pour
un public jeune qui continueront à jouer
ce rôle centralopérateurs spécialisés
pour le public jeune et j'insiste sur le
fait que les missions locales
conserveront évidemment le statut
qu'elles ont aujourd'hui aucune
disposition ne modifie en rien le statut
d'émission locale et que pour garantir
le fait que l'opérateur France travaille
à un rôle d'animation et pas un rôle de
direction de la politique de l'emploi
pratique d'illustration le
conventionnement financier des missions
locales avec l'État l'État a pourtant
70% du financement en moyenne des
missions locales restera avec l'état de
la même manière d'ailleurs que les
structures d'insertion par l'activité
économique seront toujours conventionnés
avec l'État et pas avec France travail
puisque aujourd'hui c'est même structure
ne convention ne conventionne pas pour
leur financement courant avec Pôle
emploi il n'y a pas de raison quand les
conditions conditionnent leur action à
un financement ou un accord avec France
travail il y a un aspect très technique
que je souhaite souligner qui concerne
les les systèmes informatiques et ce que
l'on appelle parfois les communes
numériques
le système d'information de Pôle Emploi
une fois transformé en France travail va
évoluer pour devenir beaucoup plus
horizontal avec la volonté que les
différents acteurs notamment ceux que
j'ai cité mais aussi les départements au
titre de l'insertion puissent partager
un maximum d'informations et accéder à
un maximum d'informations détenus
aujourd'hui par Pôle Emploi tout ça sera
évidemment précisé par des décrets qui
seront pris en lien et avec la vie
évidemment de la CNIL puisque nous
touchons à des données personnelles mais
l'objectif c'est que ce soit très
horizontal que ce soit le plus partagé
possible d'abord parce que c'est un gage
d'efficacité mais aussi parce que ce qui
nous permettra de garantir le meilleur
suivi possible des allocataires comme
des demandeurs d'emploi ce qui permettra
par exemple un conseiller demain de
France travail de prendre en charge un
demandeur d'emploi jusque là suivi par
une mission locale sans avoir à refaire
le parcours d'orientation sans avoir à
rechercher à remonter un dossier pour
connaître les formations qui ont été
suivies et donc de garantir ce qu'on
appelle
même s'il y a toujours quelques limites
des parcours sans couture l'objectif est
d'avoir des systèmes d'information
commun l'objectif est d'avoir aussi des
méthodes qui soient communes notamment
ce qu'on appelle le référentiel pour que
les différents acteurs de l'emploi
puissent
avoir et prendre demander plus
exactement les mêmes informations et la
même connaissance quel que soit le
territoire où l'on recherche un emploi
ou un suivi de manière à ce qu'on puisse
homogénéiser avoir une meilleure qualité
possible le diagnostic et l'orientation
c'est un des points faibles de notre
système aujourd'hui la manière dont on
accueille les demandeurs d'emploi la
première fois où les allocataires du RSA
la manière dont on poste le diagnostic
avec souvent trop peu de temps et
souvent des diagnostics qui sont soit
sociaux soit professionnel mais rarement
commun alors qu'on sait que la suite du
parcours relève des deux aspects
je parlais de gouvernance tout à l'heure
en disant que nous voulons l'ouvrir aux
collectivités locales aujourd'hui ce que
nous envisageons c'est que
le comité France travail le comité
d'orientation conseil d'orientation au
niveau national soit à la fois composé
de l'État évidemment de des partenaires
sociaux comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
pour lunédique et Pôle emploi mais aussi
des collectivités locales à chaque
échelon au niveau national qu'au niveau
régional ce soit là aussi un comité qui
associe les collectivités locales et
l'État avec un binôme et ta région au
niveau des régions et un binôme état
département au niveau des départements
et d'ailleurs nous prévoyons que les
présidents de départements puissent avec
les préfets notamment modifier si c'est
nécessaire les référentiels les méthodes
d'accueil pour tenir compte des
caractéristiques socio-économiques des
départements il y aura un troisième
niveau de comité France travail qui
concerne le niveau infra départemental
dans ce cas là ce que nous vous
proposons c'est que la loi ne fixe pas
les conditions du copilotage entre
l'État et les collectivités que l'on
garantisse le principe du copilotage
mais que les collectivités locales à
l'échelle des bassins d'emplois à
l'échelle des arrondissements une
échelle des intercommunalités puissent
déterminant trail quel est ou quels sont
les bons niveaux de collectivité les
plus pertinents pour assurer le
copilotage avec l'État nous savons que
sur certains bassins la problématique
d'insertion est la plus forte et le
département sera évidemment le plus
fondé dans d'autres endroits ce sont des
problématiques liées au frein à l'emploi
mobilité ou logement et dans ce cas-là
les communes et les intercommunalités
sont peut-être plus fondées aux
copilotage mais nous tenons à ce
principe de subsidiarité avant d'en
venir
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et les plus fragiles je voudrais
simplement sur la question de la
gouvernance souligner trois souligner
trois points le premier pour dire que
rien dans le texte n'organise de fusion
et nous nous voulons pas de Big Bang
institutionnel nous ne voulons pas de
fusion d'émissions locales et de Pôle
Emploi nous ne voulons pas connaître une
forme d'embolie qui accompagne chacune
des fusions dans un moment où il faut
être réactif la deuxième chose que je
veux souligner c'est que aucune
disposition du texte aucun article aucun
alinéa ne revient sur la répartition des
compétences entre les collectivités cela
répartition des compétences entre l'État
et des collectivités c'est en cela que
je dis que le texte n'est pas
recentralisateur puisqu'il n'y a pas de
modification des compétences et enfin
nous avons voulu avec cette gouvernance
ouverte aux collectivités finalement
associer les collectivités sur les
orientations de la politique de l'emploi
en général en considérant que si un des
freins à l'emploi aujourd'hui relève de
la garde d'enfants de la mobilité ou de
logement personne ne peut réussir c'est
pas ce pari sans les une activité locale
et finalement ne donnons plus de poids
aux collectivités sur la définition des
orientations il y a une difficulté que
je veux souligner devant vous mais mais
il y a des droits d'auteur sur
l'identification de cette difficulté et
donc je rends à César ce qui est à César
c'est à dire Madame la rapporteur le
fait que nous pouvons avoir nourri bien
involontairement une forme de confusion
dans la mesure où Pôle Emploi devient
France travail nous parlons d'un réseau
France travail et donc nous parlons d'un
réseau France travail avec un opérateur
qui a le même nom alors qu'il y a un
opérateur dont nous savons les
compétences aujourd'hui qui doivent être
développées puis un réseau des acteurs
de l'emploi qui poursuivent des
politiques en matière de plein emploi et
peut-être que d'avoir donné les deux
noms au réseau et à l'opérateur est une
source de confusion que l'examen nous
permettra de lever le deuxième point que
je veux souligner pour aller aussi vite
que possible concerne l'accompagnement
des demandeurs d'emploi et notamment des
plus fragiles
et je pense aux allocataires du RSA nous
savons que le constat n'est pas n'est
pas bon en matière d'accompagnement des
allocataires du RSA j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire 42% des allocataires sont
soit de manière continue soit de manière
récurrente encore au RSA 7 ans après une
première inscription nous savons que
17% soit près d'un sur cinq des
allocataires ne fait l'objet ne font
l'objet d'aucun suivi ni social ni
professionnel et ne connaissent du RSA
que la location sans aucun
accompagnement et nous savons que
seulement 33% des allocataires s'étend
après une première inscription retrouve
un emploi et pour la majorité d'entre
eux des emplois qui sont plus souvent
précaires que stables donc il faut qu'on
réinvestisse sur la question de
l'insertion et il faut qu'on retrouve
l'esprit du RMI 1988 lorsque la loi à
l'époque disait que 20% des crédits
consacrés au RMI devaient être consacré
à l'insertion et 80% à la location nous
savons tous que depuis 2004 la clé de
répartition des financements du RSA
entre l'État et les départements
qui a connu une distorsion pour ne pas
dire que les engagements n'ont pas été
tenus depuis 19 ans à la matière et donc
face à cela et dans l'attente de régler
cette question du financement la loi
vous l'avez vu ne le prévoit pas l'état
doit réinvestir sur la question de
l'insertion et accompagner à la fois les
demandeurs d'emploi via France travail
mais aussi les allocataires du RSA en
donnant plus de moyens au Conseil
départementaux pour les politiques
d'insertion c'est ce qui m'a amené à
préciser même si tout ça relève de taxes
financiers et de convention entre luidic
et Pôle emploi France travail demain
qu'une partie des moyens consacrés à
France travail à la politique France
travail se réfléchit vers les conseils
départementaux pour accompagner cet
effort d'insertion nous voulons que cela
permette à la fois un accompagnement
plus adapté et plus personnalisé des
demandeurs d'emploi et des allocataires
du RSA et je le dis dans la même phrase
dans la mesure où nous prévoyons que la
totalité des allocataires du RSA sont
aussi soit aussi inscrits auprès de Pôle
emploi parce que c'est aussi une manière
pour nous de garantir un suivi personnel
en plus du seul suivi social nous savons
que parfois c'est là que le blablet le
bas blesse nous allons rénover quelques
modalités notamment mettre en place un
contrat d'engagement réciproque qui
existe depuis 1988 mais dans le terme va
être généralisé pour les allocataires du
RSA pour les demandeurs d'emploi et en
considérant que le contre engagement le
contrat engagement jeune qui existe déjà
est une forme de contrat d'engagement
réciproque nous souhaitons que ce
contrat puisse tenir compte de l'âge de
la formation des freins en termes de
mobilité de logements de garde d'enfants
de la situation économique et la
situation de l'emploi du bassin ou
évolue la personne et de l'offre
d'insertion et de formation nous
souhaitons que ce contrat puisse
permettre d'aller jusqu'à 15 à 20h
d'activités d'insertion et de formation
par semaine ça met évidemment pas du
travail gratuit lorsqu'il y a travail il
y a contrat de travail rémunération ça
n'est évidemment pas du bénévolat
obligatoire mais il faut déterminer avec
les allocataires le type d'action et de
parcours ça peut aller
du passage du permis de conduire à la
recherche d'un logement en passant par
des jobs dating ou des ateliers
d'élaboration de réécriture de CV ou
encore des formations mais il faut que
ce soit adapté et une fois que ce
contrat est signé et adapté à la
personne tenant compte des différents
freins nous souhaitons évidemment que là
aussi comme prévu par la loi 1988 il y a
une logique de responsabilité de
contrepartie je précise que l'accès à la
location n'est pas conditionnée à la
signature du contrat la location est un
droit opposable une fois la location
obtenue il y a rédaction du contrat et
si la personne ne respecte pas les
engagements qu'elle a prises qu'elle a
pris dans le cadre du contrat là la
fonction se met en oeuvre mais parfois
on semble croire que l'on
conditionnerait l'accès au RSA a d'abord
la signature du contrat le contrat vient
après la vérification en tout cas
l'instruction du dossier des éligibilité
au RSA nous ne revenons pas sur la loi
de 88 concernant la question des
radiations et des suppressions de droits
par contre nous créons une modalité de
qui permettra aux accompagnants aux
conseillers sociaux conseillers
d'insertion professionnelle de proposer
au président du Département la
suspension pour un temps arrêté de la
location le temps que les engagements
soient pris c'est une modalité moins
forte que la radiation qui n'est pas
irréversible qui permet même lorsque la
personne réagit très vite qu'il n'y ait
aucun impact sur le montant des
indemnités de la location perçue mais
qui permet d'aller plus vite que la
réunion des équipes pluridicina
pluridisciplinaire que vous connaissez
nous avons prévu que les présidents de
départements se voient proposer cette
suspension et dans le respect là aussi
de leurs compétences qu'ils puissent
reprendre évidemment l'instruction si le
souhaitent et à défaut de réponse la
suspension serait prononcée au boulot au
bout d'un mois
nous allons aussi mais cela apparaît de
manière peut-être plus technique dans le
texte modifier quelques dispositifs en
matière de formation notamment pour
permettre l'éligibilité aux formations
dispensées dans le cadre du plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
jusqu'à un frabac + 2 alors
qu'aujourd'hui les demandeurs d'emploi
demandant à bénéficier d'une formation
dans le cadre du PIC ne doivent pas
avoir un diplôme égal ou supérieur au
bac donc nous allons élargir y compris
pour répondre aux difficultés d'accès à
l'emploi de jeunes bacheliers mais qui
après un échec parfois de moins
orientation se trouve en difficulté
d'insertion professionnelle tout en
ayant tout en ayant un bac
je termine par le troisième chantier
peut-être de manière plus rapide en
disant que nous mettons à profit ce
texte pour vous proposer d'adopter un
certain nombre de dispositions qui font
suite aux annonces du président de la
République à la suite de la fin de la
conférence nationale du handicap il y a
des mesures qui nécessitent des
dispositions législatives par exemple
faire en sorte que de droit
l'orientation au milieu ordinaire d'un
demandeur d'emploi en situation de
handicap soit la règle et qu'à défaut de
possibilité d'aller vers un milieu
ordinaire en aille vers milieu adapté il
faut l'écrire ça peut paraître étonnant
mais il faut l'écrire pour que ce soit
mise en oeuvre nous voulons que les
travailleurs en ESAT puissent bénéficier
des mêmes droits que les travailleurs
salariés à l'exception d'une disposition
que nous maintenons qui est dérogatoire
qui est l'interdiction du licenciement
parce que nous parlons là de personnes
en grande fragilité et qu'ils doivent
être protégés nous souhaitons que les
bénéficiaires d'une obligation d'emploi
par exemple après l'attribution d'une
pension d'invalidité par la Sécurité
Sociale puisse avoir les mêmes droits en
termes d'accès aux entreprises adaptées
titulaire d'une RQTH aujourd'hui lorsque
vous avez une entreprise adaptée vous ne
pouvez pas accueillir quelqu'un qui est
bénéficiaire d'une obligation d'emploi
sans RQTH donc nous voulons aligner les
droits des Boe sur les RQTH pardon pour
les acronymes et puis nous allons mettre
à profit aussi cette période pour faire
en sorte que les différentes
expérimentations notamment autour des
CDD tremplins et des Entreprises
Adaptées de travail temporaires puissent
être pérennisé et accompagné il y a un
dernier sujet que je n'évoque pas parce
que je crois madame la Présidente que
vous additionnez mon collègue
Jean-Christophe comte dans quelques
jours c'est un article sur le service
public de la petite enfance qui relève
des freins l'emploi que nous voulons
lever mais dans la mesure où
Jean-Christophe combe sera devant vous
je le laisserai évidemment présenter ces
dispositions sur lesquelles il a
travaillé je m'en arrête là madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur le Ministre
madame la rapporteur Pascal grenier
mouillé pour la partie handicap merci
même la présidente
merci Monsieur le Ministre bon ça nous
avons déjà parlé en fait de la
gouvernance bien entendu et vous l'avez
vous l'avez rappelé et je pense
effectivement
de ce qu'on appelle les un irritant on
va dire avec France travail utilisé à la
fois pour le réseau et puis à la fois
pour pour l'opérateur et créant ainsi
finalement au niveau de Pôle Emploi une
forme de hiérarchie vis-à-vis en fait
des autres opérateurs
moi je voulais juste revenir un peu sur
sur les 15 à 20h d'activités et
vous demandez ça vous en avez un peu un
peu parlé vous demandez si voilà si
c'est faisable envisageable d'indiquer
en fait ce nombre d'heures
en sachant bien entendu parce que
je fais partie des départements qui
expérimentent et puis nous on l'avait
déjà fait auparavant ou on a mis un
nombre d'heures mais qu'en revanche bien
entendu il y a beaucoup de souplesse
donc est-ce que c'est possible parce que
si on n'indique pas du tout d'heures moi
ça me semble que dans l'engagement
finalement on retrouvera pas la force de
ce de ce que vous souhaitez mettre et
que nous souhaitons y mettre en fait
et ensuite sur les droits demandeurs des
droits et devoirs pardon des demandeurs
d'emploi des bénéficiaires de RSA
comment on va concrétiser ses droits de
voix et surtout comme il y a une
inscription obligatoire et qu'en fait ça
on ne pratique pas trop avec
l'obligation du conjoint qui qui est
aussi finalement dans le respect de ces
droits et devoirs si vous pouvez un
petit peu parler plus concrètement en
fait de des attent es de ce côté parce
que je sais que c'est aussi un sujet
qui pose question en fait voilà
ensuite c'est la partie la partie
financement donc ça c'est un vrai sujet
voilà parce que dans le rapport
effectivement il y a les deux,3
à deux virus 7 milliards d'euros sur sur
trois années
donc déjà l'évaluation comment elle
comment elle a été faite qui sera mis à
contribution
est-ce que c'est l'état les départements
lunédik et les besoins
pérennes pérennes supplémentaires pour
pour France travail moi je vais juste
j'ai retrouvé
une question qui m'était posée par mon
département qui est donc expérimentateur
et qui dit voilà comment effectuera la
répartition de ses moyens
supplémentaires en sachant que
l'expérimentation donc du RSA
actuellement chez moi Pôle Emploi n'a
pas bénéficié de moyens en plus de
l'État et que c'est le département qui
finance 8P supplémentaires à Pôle emploi
et un ETP à la Mission Locale donc ça
c'est une question peut-être très
précise mais qui peut aussi apporter un
éclairage ici dans notre dans notre
réunion et ensuite est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un petit peu comment
comment vont se coordonner les
différents comités qui vont être à
différents à différents niveaux et ce
que vous attendez de plus des
collectivités qui font déjà beaucoup
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de plus
donc voilà ce sont les questions que je
voulais poser cet après-midi merci
on va prendre les questions de filet
mouillé sur la partie handicap les
articles handicap et ensuite vous
répondrez au de ces notes très bien
merci madame la Présidente peut-être
juste un préambule c'est important de
rappeler moi je voulais souligner le
travail de constatation qui a été mené
par Thibault guili avec notamment les
structures du monde du handicap c'est
important de le dire parce que c'est pas
toujours le cas mais malgré tout il
reste à sa tombe d'interrogation
la première concerne notamment
l'évolution des travailleurs handicapés
dans les ESAT avec l'idée que nous
partageons d'une convergence avec les
droits des salariés mais il s'agit d'une
mesure d'équité qui est attendue mais
qui peut s'avérer coûteuse pour les
esats et qui suscite leur inquiétude en
effet car leur modèle économique est
fragile je rappelle que un tiers d'entre
eux ne sont pas l'équilibre
et ce ne sont pas soutenus
financièrement parlant soit les
rechercheront des gains de productivité
avec notamment une incidence direct sur
les entre guillemets les travailleurs
les moins productifs
soit ils seront contraintes d'arrêter
leur activité c'est ne parviennent pas à
modifier leur positionnement étant donné
que la tendance confirmée par le projet
loi de privilégier ordinaire donc il y a
une vraie question de fond qui est de la
même de la transformation des actes qui
renvoie sur la pérennité du modèle
général alors que l'accompagnement
prévoyez-vous pour aider les ESAT à
remplir leur nouvelle obligation et ça
renvoie une question parallèle sur
l'inscription du budget des ESAT dans le
budget est-ce qu'on est sur le la
mission de travail est-ce qu'on est sur
le transfert sur la 5ème Rance il y a un
vrai sujet autour de tout cela alors
est-ce qu'on est toujours dans l'outil
de travail ou est-ce qu'on est dans
l'occupationnel qui renverrait des
questions autour des médicaments
sociales deuxième thématique les CAP
EMPLOI accompagnent leur demandeur
d'emploi en situation de handicap mais
peuvent aussi jouer un rôle important
d'appui aux entreprises et
d'identification des postes notamment
pouvoir repérer les postes accessibles
au travers handicapé or les Cap Emploi
sont déjà moins visibles déjà des
entreprises depuis le rapprochement de
Pôle emploi
dans le cas de France travail les CAP
EMPLOI vont-ils parvenir à trouver leur
place auprès des entreprises alors
autant concernant le placement et
l'accompagnement des travailleurs
handicapés on n'a pas de souci puis ça
correspond à la mission par contre
d'identification des potentiels dans les
entreprises est un autre débat dans
lequel nous avons aussi des inquiétudes
dans les rédactions même de ce qui est
faite au jeu dans le texte de loi de la
mission de Cap Emploi troisième point le
projet de loi prévoit l'inscription
automatique sur la liste des demandeurs
d'emploi de toute personne en recherche
d'emploi y compris les personnes qui
sollicitent un accompagnement par un
cadre point de bénéficiaires du RSA or
ne risque-t-on pas de laisser de côté
une partie des personnes en situation de
handicap qui ne se perçoivent comme trop
éloigné de l'emploi qui est le même
imagine même pas qu'ils ont une
opportunité alors qu'elle demande quand
même une RQTH voilà et donc est-ce qu'il
y a pas une relation différente à
trouver peut-être une autonométrisation
des inscriptions auprès de France
travail en sachant que l'autonomie ou le
choix des personnes handicapées est déjà
réalisé puisque c'est elle-même qui font
la démarche de l'air QTH voilà et donc
pour bien connaître le milieu notamment
sur les personnes qui sont lourdement
handicapées qui peuvent considérer
qu'elles l'emploi c'est pas pour elle
alors qu'elles ont réellement des
opportunités elle risque de passer à
côté d'un accompagnement et je t'aimerai
tout simplement pour vous dire que dans
les amendements que nous allons regarder
nous regardons très près le débat
concernant les personnes qui sont
lourdement handicapées qui avaient été
entre guillemets oubliée lors de la
réforme de l'ETH il y avait des mesures
particulières et donc ce sera l'occasion
certainement de revoir ce sujet là
c'est Monsieur le Ministre peut-être
pour répondre déjà c'est de questions
ensuite merci sur la question du du nom
du réseau ni non l'opérateur c'est un
point qu'on peut certainement éclaircir
et donc si on arrive à regarder et avoir
comment bien éclaircir et bien
différencier ce qui relève de
l'opérateur et qui relève du réseau des
acteurs de l'emploi peut-être que j'ai
commencé à appeler réseau d'acteurs
d'emploi sera plus parlant en laissant à
l'opérateur le seul nom France travail
ça sera mieux et sachant mais la loi le
dit et je ne souhaite pas que je
souhaite que la confusion puisse être
levée le plus rapidement possible on a
un opérateur qui n'a pas vocation à
décider ou à déterminer la politique des
autres les départements restent dans
leur compétences les collectivités à
tous niveaux reste dans leurs
compétences comme je disais aucune
disposition du texte ne reprend une
enquête sur les compétences des
collectivités et c'est vraiment un point
auquel j'ai veillé je dis parfois dans
un sourire mais je ne suis pas sûr que
le gouvernement ait eu une majorité au
Sénat pour modifier la répartition des
compétences entre collectivité ou entre
les collectivités et l'État donc ça m'a
plutôt amené une forme de prudence sur
le sujet et à produire un texte qui ne
touche pas à cela et qui ne soit pas
dans cette logique de recentralisation
sur la question des 15 à 20h je pense
qu'on peut évidemment préciser la salle
nuance ou le seul bémol que je mets aux
propos de Madame la rapporteur tiens à
deux difficultés la première c'est que
lorsqu'on dit qu'il faut avoir une
activité des activités entre 15 et 20
heures par semaine dès lors qu'elles
sont définies adaptées personnalisés ça
signifie que collectivement la puissance
publique à tout niveau
garantit la présence de 15 à 20 heures
d'activités sur tous les territoires ce
qui n'est pas nécessairement une
évidence en tout cas ça peut prendre un
petit peu de temps la deuxième la
deuxième chose c'est que nous avons des
allocataires du RSA qui parfois sont
dans un isolement et une rupture depuis
extrêmement longtemps et pour lesquelles
on sait que
imaginer 15 amateurs d'activités dès les
premières semaines de mise en œuvre d'un
contrat serait extrêmement compliqué
d'ailleurs nous avons prévu dans la loi
que les plus éloignés puissent
bénéficier d'un accompagnement social
avant même d'aller vers un
accompagnement professionnel parce que
c'est parfois nécessaire pour ceux qui
en sont beaucoup trop loin et donc
pouvoir préciser l'objectif j'en suis
preneur mais en faisant attention de ne
pas nous-même nous enfermer dans quelque
chose qui ne serait pas réaliste ou
réalisable sur
la question des conjoints en réalité la
réforme que je vous propose met à jour
des règles qui existent aujourd'hui qui
sont assez méconnues aujourd'hui lorsque
vous bénéficiez du RSA lorsque vous êtes
allocataire du RSA
c'est un minimum social qui est
familiarisé et dont l'attribution dépend
pas de vos seuls revenus mais des
revenus du foyer fiscal et lorsque un
couple bénéficie du RSA ou une personne
en couple plus exactement bénéfique du
RSA ce que les allocataires ne savent
pas parce que la réalité que c'est très
peu mise en oeuvre c'est qu'en réalité
les droits et les devoirs qui existent
déjà dans la loi de 1988 s'applique au
couple et pas seulement à le locataire
qui a monté le dossier fait
et donc on est dans une situation où
effectivement l'inscription automatique
des allocataires du RSA auprès de Pôle
Emploi entraînerait l'inscription de la
locataire et de son conjoint dans le cas
où le conjoint n'occupe pas un emploi et
donc ça relève plutôt de la gestion mais
c'est des choses qu'il faut préciser y
compris parce que nous savons que dans
un couple si l'un des membres du couple
a des revenus très bas le second
peut-être un locataire du RSA et on ne
va pas demander à quelqu'un qui
travaille d'être inscrit chez Pôle
Emploi ça n'aurait aucun sens mais ça
relève plutôt de la gestion et de
l'accompagnement et pour les couples qui
malheureusement sont tous les deux dans
la dans la dans la précarité
le suivi pour les deux est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle et une avancée qu'il soit
en couple ou célibataire
sur le rôle des collectivités locales
j'ai envie de vous dire pas plus mais
mieux c'est à dire mieux coordonner
aujourd'hui nous considérons que les
collectivités agissent qu'elles agissent
dans leur champ de compétences que nous
modifions pas mais que la création de
comité France travail au niveau local
des parcs mental des régionales permet
une meilleure coordination et permet
d'associer les collectivités à la
définition des orientations que mettre
en oeuvre France travaille c'est en ça
que nous attendons des collectivités ça
n'est pas de faire à la place de l'État
ça sera un mauvais une mauvaise demande
un mauvais procès ça n'est pas de faire
différemment mais bien de coordonner ce
qui se passe et c'est qu'elles mettent
en oeuvre et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous prévoyons trois niveaux
régional départemental et locale
enfin avant de venir aux questions liées
au handicap la question du financement
le rapport Thibault guili estime que le
besoin cumulé sur trois ans du projet
France travail va varie de 2 milliards 7
c'est quelque chose de nécessairement
progressif puisque vous avez vu que dans
le texte beaucoup des dispositions
seront appliquées de manière généralisée
qu'à partir du 1er janvier 2025 et en
fonction de la trajectoire que nous
voulons suivre nous aurons un besoin qui
sera peut-être de 300 ou dans les entre
300 peut-être et 500 millions en 2024
comment est-ce que c'est financé comment
est-ce que nous envisageons d'abord
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui dans le
cas du PLF il y a des crédits qui sont
affectés par l'État au financement de
Pôle emploi et demain de France travail
ces crédits peuvent être augmentés c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
c'est que 80% du financement de Pôle
Emploi aujourd'hui relève d'un
financement par lunédique puisque
l'unique lunédique verse 11% de ses
recettes à France travail à Pôle Emploi
pardon
c'est 11% de recettes vu la dynamique
que nous connaissons sur la masse
salariale et les créations d'emplois
cela représente déjà une augmentation de
recettes de 400 millions d'euros l'année
prochaine sans modifier le taux la seule
dynamique de l'assiette fait qu'il y a
400 millions supplémentaires la
convention tripartite entre l'état d'une
édic et Pôle emploi de maintenance
travail doit être renégocié d'ici la fin
de l'année et dans la mesure où la
trajectoire d'excédent de lunédique est
assez massif uneédie qui est passée
d'une situation où il y avait un déficit
d'un milliard 9 par an pendant 10 ans à
peu près à une situation l'excédent et
de 4 milliards en 2022 il est prévu par
l'inédit à 8000 R7 en 2024 et nous
estimons qu'en 2027 il sera la
fourchette est très large mais entre 10
milliards si nous sommes un taux de
chômage de 7% et 18 milliards si nous
sommes un taux de chômage de 5% la
fourchette est large parce que il y a un
double effet sur les recettes et sur les
dépenses si la création d'emplois et
baisse du nombre du nombre de chômeurs
et donc il y a des possibilités je pense
de participation et de financement pour
pour tout cela
sur les questions du de handicap il
s'agit évidemment pas de remettre en
cause le modèle des esats mais bien
d'être sur une convergence de droit et
le premier droit qui va coûter tient
plutôt la mutuelle en réalité puisque
quand on parle de droit de grève de
droit syndical de droit à la mobilité ce
ne sont pas des choses scooters c'est
plutôt de la mise en œuvre ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que
on a un une forme d'obligation presque
d'obligation morale 80% aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui fait le lien avec les
mutuelles 80% des travailleurs en ESAT à
temps plein en ESAT non pas de mutuelle
et de complémentaires santé je pense pas
que ce soit acceptable en soi par contre
ça nécessite effectivement que le plan
de transformation des ESAT qui a été
mise en oeuvre il y a maintenant trois
ans je crois puisqu'on continuer et que
s'il y a prise en charge de dépenses
nouvelles nous puissions aussi répondre
à ces dépenses nouvelles ça c'est la
première chose et nous devons aussi
travailler sur notre aspect ce que moi
j'appelle le droit au retour nous
voulons faciliter les mobilités et
notamment le passage de l'ESAT à Leha ou
de l'ESAT au milieu or mais il faut
pouvoir sécuriser le retour en cas
d'échec parce que comme dans toute
trajectoire professionnelle il peut y
avoir il peut y avoir un échec sur
les ESAT je vous ai dit sur Cap emploi
c'est un opérateur spécialisé reconnu
par le projet de loi et la question de
l'identification des potentiels dans
l'entreprise fait partie des priorités
qu'on veut donner à Cap emploi dans ce
cadre-là et pour avoir un pour avoir
rencontré le réseau Keops c'est leur
demande aussi donc il y a largement
matière à travailler et avancer et enfin
sur la question des RQTH que vous avez
évoqué et de l'inscription automatique
c'est un point que je n'avais pas dans
le radar à vrai dire donc peut-être
qu'il faut qu'on le regarde voir comment
le mettre en oeuvre parce que c'est vrai
que la demande de RQTH est en initiative
de la personne ça peut justifier
l'inscription automatique et j'en
précise pour souligner mais vous le
savez parce que vous étiez à la CNH que
nous allons prendre le décret pour
pour casser ce frein à l'emploi pour les
bénéficiaires de la H2 puisque vous
savez que les bénéficiaires de la H2
peuvent cumuler la location avec une un
revenu salarié de manière dégressive et
plafonnée à condition de ne pas
travailler plus de 17h30 par semaine
alors certains d'entre eux le peuvent et
le modèle est stupide à ce point que
même les contrats aidés ne sont du coup
plus accessibles à des allocataires de
la H2 puisqu'ils sont sur des bases de
25 heures donc il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on puisse déplafonner tout ça
et c'est réglementaire c'est par contre
alors question plusieurs commissaires
emiliane Pomerol Jean-Marie Daniel
Chassin Monique Lubin Laurence
on va peut-être couper en deux
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre vous avez
répondu partiellement à certaines de mes
questions mais je voudrais y revenir
parce que d'abord je me dérange sur la
temporalité de ce projet de loi
temporalité puisque il y a une
expérimentation qui a démarré qui
viennent tout juste de démarrer dans 18
départements et j'ai l'impression
d'avoir un vécu identique on l'a connu
ça aussi sur un texte de loi sur la
santé ou l'expérimentation n'était pas
encore lancée que deux mois après
modifier
un projet de loi et là on est dans le
même circonstance c'est à dire qu'il y a
une expérimentation qui vient à peine de
démarrer que vous vous présentez un
projet de loi plus ou moins ficelier et
qui donc se posent la question de
l'intérêt de s'expérimentation ça
c'était ma première question ensuite sur
le fait vous avez répondu partiellement
mais sur le fait de l'obligation de
description pour tout de personne y
compris le RSA et vous l'avez expliqué
le conjoint ce qu'on comprend bien
puisque effectivement c'est une
allocation différentielle et que les
revenus conjoint entre en ligne de
compte quel est le but que vous
poursuivez derrière cette inscription
obligatoire de l'ensemble des personnes
qui sont aujourd'hui
suivis accompagnés non seulement en tant
que chercheur d'emploi mais parce que
ils ont besoin d'un accompagnement
spécifique soit par la Mission locale
soit par soit par Cap emploi et donc
quel est l'intérêt vraiment enfin moi je
voudrais avoir des précisions sur le but
que vous poursuivez à travers cette
inscription généralisée vous vous dites
ensuite et c'est quelque chose qui me
gêne aussi parce que plusieurs fois dans
le texte vous parlez de décision qui
seront pris alors il y a un comité
d'orientation on ne sait pas très bien
d'ailleurs comment ça va fonctionner
mais en plus ce qui me gêne c'est que
vous parlez à plusieurs reprises de
décisions qui seront prises par décret
précisé par décret ou par arrêter ce qui
veut dire que aujourd'hui on va voter
sur un texte et que c'est ensuite le
ministre
ou en tout cas au moins le gouvernement
qui décidera tout seul des modalités
pratiques à appliquer donc c'est quand
même quelque chose qui me qui est gênant
dans le principe même du texte de loi
sur les 15 à 20h vous avez un petit peu
expliqué mais on aimerait quand même
avoir un petit peu plus de précision sur
la nature parce que dans le texte on
retrouve pas le terme de 15 à 20 heures
voir le un écrit 15 à 20h d'activité par
semaine mais voilà bon avoir des
précisions là-dessus enfin je voudrais
insister aussi sur les moyens financiers
sur les moyens financiers vous vous
évoquez la ressource miraculeuse que va
être l'unique pour qui va être
en pleine forme j'allais dire dans les
années qui viennent puisque ce que vous
nous de nous dire avec des milliards qui
vont qui vont survivre de partout il
empêche que sur les moyens humains en
particulier vu l'augmentation de
responsabilité et de travail que vous
donnez aux agents de Pôle Emploi est-ce
que vous avez dans ce projet prévu
d'augmenter les moyens de Pôle Emploi
donc de France travaille aujourd'hui
opérateur et il y a en même temps dans
cette partie de l'article 2 si je dis
pas de bêtises
la possibilité de faire faire par du
privé genre Adecco manpower etc des
offres d'emploi et je me demande s'il y
a pas un glissement ici encore d'un
service public de l'emploi vers une
privatisation qui serait
plus ou moins à bas bruit mais qui me
semble assez évidente ouais c'est pour
les premières questions que je voulais
poser aujourd'hui
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai présidé pendant une bonne
vingtaine d'années un pli on a créé
pendant ces 20 ans la Maison de l'emploi
qui abritait le pli puis on a abrité la
mission locale on l'a fusionné entre le
pli et la mission locale on a abrité
maintenant la Cité des Métiers et le
pôle formation du conseil régional
et on a toujours eu une difficulté
qui pouvait être résolu
partiellement avec les avec tel
directeur de Pôle emploi parce que dans
l'esprit de Pôle Emploi ce sont les
seuls acteurs de services publics de
l'emploi le problème il est à ce niveau
là c'est pour ça j'aborde par cet angle
la gouvernance Pôle emploi et c'est
normal d'ailleurs c'est une agence de
droit public donc ils ont des
prérogatives que je conteste absolument
pas mais comme vous voulez mettre tout
ça en réseau et vous avez parfaitement
raison j'applaudis j'applaudis vraiment
cette volonté mais vous allez vous
heurter à cette difficulté donc la
confusion entre France travail et Pôle
emploi
va accroître cette difficulté moi c'est
mon sentiment deuxième point et là je
vous approuve totalement c'est qu'il a
décentralisation est indispensable le
copilotage en infra départementale c'est
essentiel et vous l'avez parfaitement
souligné parce que les cas sont divers
et variés et le rôle
je dirais la situation économique sur le
territoire situation sociale peuvent
être très différentes donc c'est
important d'associer tous les opérateurs
à ce niveau là un frein départemental
souvent d'ailleurs dans mon département
au niveau des intercos qui ont
compétences souvent sont donnés les
compétences dans ce domaine alors j'ai
de ce fait deux ou trois questions
premièrement
il faut s'assurer que c'est une demande
notamment des réseaux de mission locale
et de plis que l'inscription à Pôle
Emploi sera pas obligatoire et autrement
dit l'inscription à la Mission locale
par exemple pour les jeunes vaudra
inscription à France travail c'est une
question qui est posée et qui me paraît
importante pour éviter des doublons et
ont hésiter des concurrences
deuxièmement la relation avec les
employeurs
ça je l'ai vécu nous avions créé dans le
cadre de cette maison une coordination
entre Pôle emploi et tous les opérateurs
qui a bien fonctionné
tant qu'il y avait effectivement une
volonté de la part de Pôle emploi de
jouer le jeu
c'est essentiel parce que vous le savez
parfaitement
un employeur une entreprise qui voit
défiler 2 3 4 conseillers des différents
opérateurs pour essayer de connaître la
situation du marché de l'emploi à la
situation effectivement de l'embauche ça
déplaît ça irrite et ça a des effets
totalement inverse de ce rechercher donc
il faut coordonner à ce niveau là et
obliger Pôle emploi à jouer le jeu à ne
pas s'octroyer un droit qu'il n'arrive
pas à assumer ensuite
et le dernier point parce que je vais
être assez bref quand même sur le RSA
bon les moyens qu'elles vont être les
moyens pour accompagner réellement
actuellement en moyenne ils ont dans les
départements suivant la situation
financière des départements moins de 10%
de consacrer à la campagnement ça est
très bien et d'ailleurs à l'initiative
enfin disons au moment de la création du
RSA on avait parlé plutôt de 20 à 25%
consacrés est-ce que vous pouvez nous
assurer que vous aurez les moyens
effectivement d'assurer ça à chaque
département
merci
merci madame la Présidente je suis le
ministre donc accéder au travail c'est
s'émanciper s'insérer dans la société et
pour soi-même mais aussi pour sa famille
et on voit que les 2 millions de RSA et
bien il y a toujours 61% qui sont là
depuis plus de 2 ans et 37 % depuis
depuis 5 ans alors tout ça c'est parce
que en fait les personnes en RSA
ont la crainte de perdre le RSA et
surtout les droits connexes alors
quelques trois questions n'est-il pas
nécessaire pour les personnes éloignées
de l'emploi et c'est la grande majorité
d'avoir un accompagnement bien sûr comme
vous l'avez dit personnalisé adapté mais
en proposant d'abord simplement la
découverte de l'entreprise de l'emploi
de la découverte de cette de l'Emploi de
la Formation et aussi une remise à
niveau scolaire et bien sûr concernant
les suspension éventuelle il faut avant
bien sûr que l'accompagnement soit bien
effectif avec le logement la mobilité
des garde d'enfants etc
troisièmement ça a été dit plusieurs
fois deuxièmement c'était plusieurs fois
monsieur le ministre pour mener à bien
cette mission qui est quelque chose
d'économique mais aussi un projet social
et bien il faut avoir les moyens pour
comme vous l'avez dit la coordination
entre l'État le département la région
mais aussi et ça a été dit avec renforcé
aussi les aides aux entreprises adaptées
et aux ESAT pour bien accompagner et
donc
c'est ma deuxième question les moyens et
aussi alors la troisième c'est si vous
voulez ici on avait voté au niveau de la
commission
PPL de président maluré qui indiquait
que après 9 mois de chômage
après un an de chômage on pouvait
effectivement
conserver le RSA pendant 9 mois à partir
du moment où on est rentré dans l'emploi
et est-ce que ça ça serait pas bien
aussi notamment pour pour les seniors
merci
merci madame le Président Monsieur le
Ministre je souhaitais vous interpeller
vous interroger sur deux points que vous
avez développé mais pour autant les
choses ne sont pas assez précises dans
vos réponses me semble-t-il le premier
concerne la gouvernance et en
particulier la place et le rôle des
collectivités locales et en termes de
collectivités locales je veux parler des
régions et des départements vous avez
indiqué et cela est une réalité c'est
bien de le rappeler que ce n'est pas une
loi en tout cas dans cette proposition
qui pourrait remettre en question la
compétence de des collectivités dans le
cas de grande loi de décentralisation
c'est bien le parlement qui devrait
ainsi en décider et donc vous ne faites
pas une proposition aussi précise que
celle-là dans votre texte mais pour
autant vous proposer de partager de
partager ces compétences partager une
compétence exclusive des régions qui est
celle de la formation professionnelle
des demandeurs d'emploi qui leur a été
transférer depuis près de 40 ans
maintenant peut-être un peu plus les
grandes lois de des centralisation donc
une compétence partagée est en région
les compétence partagée est en région de
la même façon pour les départements on
peut aussi s'inquiéter ou s'interroger
sur une compétence aussi qui est le cœur
de métier qui est celle de l'insertion
l'insertion sociale et qui serait là
aussi partager des départements pour que
ce partage puisse se faire et que des
co-présidents puissent
s'organiser au niveau des comités locaux
on va dire que soit un comité régional
France travail ou un comité
départemental France travail il faudrait
le texte indique que ces collectivités
concernées signent une charte
d'engagement
voilà mais Queen ma question précise que
se passerait-il si l'une ou l'autre de
ces collectivités ne signait pas cette
charte d'engagement est-ce que l'État
seul
prendrait en charge ou vous serez cette
compétence que concerne la formation
professionnelle des demandeurs d'emploi
ou bien l'aspect et le volet insertion
porté par les départements donc ça ça
concerne donc la gouvernance et encore
une fois le rôle et la place des
collectivités locales et mon autre
question porte sur le financement vous
avez donc indiqué qu'il appartiendra au
moment des débats budgétaires de définir
précisément quel moyen serait
donnée comment l'État le gouvernement
propose donc de doter les différents
instances de différentes partenaires les
différentes collectivités locales pour
mener à bien cette réforme d'une
certaine façon qui transforme Pôle
emploi en France travail et vous avez
évoqué un financement possible de la
part de l'inédith
une éthique qui aujourd'hui reverse 11%
à Pôle Emploi pardon il me semble avoir
vu que
certaines estimations ou pouvaient être
envisagées une augmentation de cette
contribution de 15 à 16%. et vous
indiquez que
l'unique pourrait accompagner donc c'est
financements car l'unique est
excédentaire j'ai repris vos chiffres
pour prochainement plus de 4 milliards
d'euros
et plus encore pour les années à venir
je si je peux me permettre monsieur le
ministre sans vouloir vous manquer de
respect vous avez oublié d'évoquer la
dette et l'endettement très important de
l'inéditique qui fait qui due non
seulement la crise économique de 2008
mais aussi à la crise sanitaire parce
que l'inédit qui a joué un rôle
extrêmement important pour permettre aux
salariés dans le cadre de chômage
partiel de continuer à percevoir une une
rémunération un tout d'endettement un
niveau d'endettement qui est supérieur à
18 milliards d'euros donc voilà je me
permets juste sans sans
comment dire sans polémique de rappeler
cela et donc moi j'aurais souhaité nous
aurons souhaité quand même que dans ce
texte il soit évoqué quelques lignes
quelques orientations sur ce financement
qui est considérable mais qui au regard
aussi des auditions que nous avons pu
mener lorsque le rapport Gilly annonce
2,2 milliards à 2,7 milliards sur trois
ans on serait 13 ans de ça si vraiment
les objectifs fixés dans cette ce projet
de loi sont sont bien là on serait très
en de ça des moyens nécessaires merci
voilà alors vous souhaitez répondre ou
on prend aussi madame Cohen madame Cohen
et moi je vais devoir vous quitter
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre je vais poser en
fait deux questions qui sont assez
brèves l'article 1er prévoit un
triplement du plafond de la prime Macron
et l'exonération de prélèvements sociaux
je dirais dans la plupart des cas
l'article 2 instaure de nouvelles
exonérations de cotisations pour les
indépendants dont la compensation par
l'État est
pardon madame alors je me suis trompé de
steakrice c'est exactement
je suis en train de me dire qu'est-ce
que je suis en train de dire bon bah
voilà bah écoutez je passe mon tour
alors là c'est sympa chers collègues
je ne répète pas mais surtout avec la
réforme
c'est ça
merci monsieur le Président je peux
aussi répondre à madame la sénatrice sur
le partage de la valeur mais comme cela
viendra devant votre assemblée en
octobre modulo la remarque de madame la
Présidente de la Commission je peut-être
que nous pouvons faire avant
effectivement en tout cas avoir le débat
mais mes équipes sont Emmanuel c'est ma
voix disposition sur les différents
points qui ont été évoqués d'abord pour
répondre à Madame pomirol sur la
temporalité entre expérimentation et loi
c'est une discussion que nous avons eu
évidemment avec la DF puisque nous avons
beaucoup travaillé avec l'ADF pour
avancer la loi comme vous l'avez vu et
vous l'avez dit ne détermine pas une
liste pas les activités la nature des
activités des 15 inventeurs d'abord
parce que ça n'est pas un niveau
législatif et puis il serait un peu
contre-productif d'enfermer l'action des
acteurs de l'emploi dans une liste
définie par la loi d'activité
potentielles alors que ça relève de la
gestion
les expérimentations que nous menons
avec 18 départements vise à avoir ce qui
marche le mieux en termes
d'accompagnement dans des territoires
très différents et je me suis engagé
auprès des départements signataires
d'expérimentation je leur ai tous écrits
pour cela parce que le financement
l'expérimentation soit garanti en 2023
et en 2024 la loi prévoit la
généralisation de ce nouvel
accompagnement à partir de 2025 et donc
les expérimentations qui sont menées
permettent et ça n'est pas du niveau
législatif mais permettent de voir tout
ce qui peut marcher tout ce qui peut
être recommandé pour la génération la
généralisation 2025 et la loi nous
permet par contre de fixer un cadre dont
nous avons besoin et sans être
prescriptif et d'ailleurs c'était aussi
une demande des départements de France
de ne pas enfermer leur action en termes
d'insertion et d'accompagnement dans une
liste d'activités posées par la loi le
rapport thibault-ghilie à la toute fin
c'est la page 265 fait une liste de
d'exemples d'action et de de d'action
d'accompagnement qui sont mises en œuvre
mais c'est uniquement un titre
d'illustration et de des bonnes
pratiques donc on n'a pas de problème de
temporalité puisque c'est à partir 2025
ça sera véritablement généralisé et les
expérimentations vont permettre de
préparer et de nourrir cette
généralisation et je pense que d'ici à
la fin de l'année 2024 il sera utile
mais semble substituer évidemment au
Parlement d'avoir un temps d'échange
d'évaluation sur ces expérimentations
justement pour en tirer le meilleur
avant la généralisation de 2025 mais ça
relève de pratique et non pas de
disposition législatives et il y a
évidemment quelques décrets qui sont
prévus d'ailleurs je pense que c'est
mieux ainsi pour certains aspects
notamment sur les systèmes d'information
puisque en renvoyant la création des
systèmes d'information à des décrets ça
nous permet aussi de prendre des décrits
après la vie conforme de la CNIL ce qui
lorsqu'on parle de données personnelles
et est assez utile et donc nous
travaillons de ce point de vue et nous
pourrons évidemment les partager sur la
question des acteurs privés et notamment
des agences d'intérim la loi ne leur
donne aucune prérogative nouvelle par
rapport à ce qui existe aujourd'hui par
contre bien évidemment et ça existe déjà
il y a un certain nombre d'endroits où
les acteurs de l'emploi que ce soit Pôle
emploi ou d'autres s'appuient aussi sur
des opérateurs privés et il y a un
centre de coopération qui existe
aujourd'hui entre les acteurs publics et
les acteurs privés je prends un exemple
le ministère du Travail a initié les
maintenance 18 mois un partenariat avec
une partie des opérateurs d'intérim
notamment sur le partage des données et
la capacité à mieux analyser leur propre
base de données et celle de Pôle Emploi
pour réduire des tensions de recrutement
et mieux orienter mieux définir les les
offres qui sont transmises aux
demandeurs et des profils transmis au
recruteurs les moyens financiers ont été
évoqués et par presque tous les
intervenants donc je m'y arrête un
instant
pour dire d'une part que la situation de
Pôle Emploi aujourd'hui doit être
regardé avec attention bien évidemment
pour les questions d'accompagnement mais
en portant à votre en appelant votre
attention sur le fait que depuis 2017
Pôle emploi a bénéficié de 4000
créations de poste dans une période où
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi à crus
et donc on a aussi des postes qui ont
été créés à l'occasion du plan de
relance ou du plan d'urgence pour
accompagner des initiatives et il y a
certainement des redéploiements
envisagés parce que c'est un phénomène
souvent négligé ou oublié mais c'est
plus 4000 postes nous sommes aujourd'hui
à presque 52000 ETP titulaire et
contractuel sur Pôle Emploi contre un
peu plus de 47000 au début du premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron alors que
le nombre de demandeurs et le nombre et
le taux de chômage approfondément baissé
sur les moyens financiers je disais
l'État verse une subvention de
fonctionnement à Pôle Emploi nous allons
continuer elle peut être réévaluée mais
c'est à l'occasion du PLF que ça se
discute et la la participation de
l'inédith existe aujourd'hui elle doit
être red société dans le cadre de du
renouvellement de la convention très
petite les chiffres qui ont été vus je
crois que c'est Madame Ferré que les a
évoqué le passage le 11 à 17 sont des
estimations de type produits en croix
qui ont été faits par d'autres que le
gouvernement que nous ne reprenons pas
notre compte parce que je ne suis pas du
tout convaincu que ce soit nécessaire et
que ce soit ce chiffre là mais j'ai vu
ces chiffres comme vous c'est un produit
en croix en disant si on passe de temps
d'accompagnement renforcé à temps la
multiplication aboutirait ce résultat là
c'est vraiment des chiffres dans la
nature mais en tout cas ce ne sont pas
les chiffres du gouvernement lieu n'est
dit connaît par contre une trajectoire
que l'humidité présentait le même comme
très excédentaire j'ai indiqué les
chiffres tout à l'heure 8 milliards 7
dès 2024 et potentiellement jusqu'à 18
milliards en 2027 par an ça permet en
cas d'augmentation de la contribution
d'une édique à la fois de financer des
mesures nouvelles pour l'emploi et la
réduction du nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi sans contrarier la trajectoire
de désendettement de l'édit parce que
l'ampleur des accidents qui sont
annoncés permet de poursuivre les deux
objectifs je sais que les acteurs du net
notamment les partenaires sociaux
souhaitent la reprise de dettes par
l'État en considérant que la dette
notamment liée à la période du covid
devrait être prise vous imaginez que
comme ancien ministre du Budget je n'ai
pas encore
une conviction aussi affirmer que leur
sur le sur le sujet sur les questions
relatives à l'automaticité des
inscriptions c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'automatique et donc les les
personnes qui demandent par exemple le
RSA et qui l'obtiennent se verront
signifier que l'obtention du RSA
signifie l'inscription de la même
manière que ceux qui s'inscrivent à la
Mission locale se verront signifié que
cela vaut inscription auprès de Pôle
emploi et l'objectif qui est le nôtre ça
reboucle avec la question même poumiral
c'est de garantir le suivi professionnel
tout à l'heure je disais que 17% des
allocataires n'ont aucun suivi ni social
ni professionnel seul 45% ont un suivi
professionnel et de la même manière que
nous voulons que le diagnostic soit
double social et professionnel nous
voulons que le suivi soit double social
et professionnel
adapter bien sûr mais l'inscription
auprès de France travail Pôle Emploi
aujourd'hui permet de garantir ce suivi
professionnel et de maximiser les
chances de retour à l'emploi c'est le
seul objectif que nous que nous
poursuivons sur les moyens ça fait le
lien avec le financement effectivement
il faut retrouver cette ambition de 88
Jean
j'ai pas d'argent Jean-Marie monerenberg
le rappelait en 1988 la loi disait que
20% des sommes consacrées au RMI devait
aller à l'insertion en 99 cette fraction
a été ramenée à 16 ou 17% et en 2004
avec la décentralisation du RSA au
département
l'obligation a été purement et
simplement supprimer des textes
aujourd'hui nous sommes plutôt sur une
moyenne 9% ça s'explique par des
questions c'est très variable mais c'est
une moyenne à neuf ça s'explique parfois
pour des questions de volonté politique
ça s'explique aussi par la distorsion du
financement de la location telle que ça
s'est accumulé depuis depuis 2004
sur les questions d'accès aux droits oui
c'est évidemment un point et je fais
aussi le lien même si étant par l'été
pour le coup ne sont pas les mêmes entre
ce projet le fait que nous travaillons
sur la solidarité automatique pour faire
en sorte que les aides dont bénéfiques
ton peuvent bénéficier les contribuables
les usagers puissent être attribués et
revalorisé automatiquement vous savez
l'immensité du chantier informatique que
cela représente et le temps que cela que
cela prend sur enfin l'intervention de
Madame Ferret deux points
madame sénatrice pas de compétences
partagées gouvernance oui mais pas de
compétences partagées vraiment j'insiste
sur ce point et nous parlons de
gouvernance et ce que nous proposons en
réalité c'est que au niveau régional
départemental et même au niveau national
les collectivités puissent être dans les
comités et les conseils France travail
pour participer aux orientations que
l'opérateur devra mettre en oeuvre mais
la région est compétence pour la
formation et l'État ne prend rien de
cette compétence de la même façon que le
département était responsable de son
plan départemental d'insertion dans le
la loi bien sûr et qu'on ne reprend rien
la matière c'est une association des
collectivités aux orientations ça n'est
pas un partage de compétences j'y veille
très très scrupuleusement et la charte
d'engagement que vous avez évoqué a pour
objectif notamment d'organiser le
partage d'infos et le partage de données
dans le cadre des nouveaux systèmes
d'information je sais parce que ça fait
un peu débat en disant mais attendez si
on Stimme pas la charte est-ce que ça
veut dire vous reprenez la compétence la
réponse est NON et donc peut-être qu'il
faut qu'on creuse un peu ce point là
pour que cette charte qui est une charte
vise à partager les principes la
composition des différents comités et
l'organisation de du partage des données
soit bien perçues pour ce qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire avant toi un outil de
travail et pas un outil de subordination
très bien il nous reste s'il vous plaît
il nous reste 5 intervenants la réponse
ministre on a 14 minutes donc je vendais
très rapide René Paul c'est vrai oui
merci monsieur le ministre je vous
souhaite bonne chance parce que je suis
pas sûr le remettre une réorganisation
dans le bon sens c'est quand même une
centralisation de l'organisation de de
ce type d'activité 1 deuxièmement
monsieur le ministre ça sert à rien
d'inscrire des gens qui s'o RSA et qui
sont des gens qui doivent bénéficier
d'une insertion sociale faut surtout pas
pour certains les mettre au travail chez
des élèves on connaît tout ça il y a des
gens qu'il faut pas mettre au travail il
y a d'autres actions à faire cela faut
pas les inscrire au travail ne dites pas
que c'est une loi de plein emploi va
c'est pas 5% que vous allez avoir en
inscrivant tout ça au chômage vous
n'avez pas ça 10% d'inscription ces lois
de pleine inscription au chômage c'est
de plein inscriptions et c'est pas une
loi de de plein emploi maisons bruty
deuxièmement un truc bien quand même je
vais venir système d'information
partagée oui mais il faut que ça soit
partagé avec la région le département et
l'État qu'on arrive au même système
d'information troisièmement et là c'est
moins bien c'est un moins bon point
c'est que les décideurs sont plus les
payeurs quoi le payeur n'est plus le
décideur puisque vous faites à chaque
fois état région état est un département
est un collectivité locale ce qui veut
dire que chacun garde sa compétence sauf
que il est dans cette direction là
voyez-vous je ne suis pas comme ça que
j'aurais pris le problème moi ceux qui
dépendent de l'insertion sociale c'est
le département ensuite il y a ceux qui
ont une insertion sociale et
professionnelle avec normalement surtout
de la formation c'est la région et
ensuite c'est l'insertion
professionnelle là c'est l'état c'est
comme ça qu'il fallait voir en fonction
de ce public avec un parcours du public
ça m'aurait semblait une meilleure
organisation et genre termine là
simplement il faut vraiment que si j'ai
bien compris une différence par rapport
à l'existence parce que ça on enfonce
des portes ouvertes je suis désolé mais
ça existe déjà quand on veut le faire
moi quand je préside département 80%
étaient inscrit à Pôle emploi c'est pas
moi autant qui trouvait de l'emploi ok
ce qui est en me semble-t-il c'est que
l'éligibilité au RSA ça c'est la
condition à remplir pour avoir des
droits mais il y a des droits et des
devoirs et c'est là que le contrat doit
être respecté et c'est là que ça veut
dire que il y a une action à faire parce
que c'est rendre service à ces personnes
de pouvoir s'engager dans des devoirs on
les responsabilise merci
merci tout d'abord je vous prie de
m'excuser pour mes lunettes j'ai oublié
mes lunettes de vue claires donc pour
lire je mets excusez-moi
le monsieur le ministre le service
public de l'emploi il existe le travail
avec les collectivités locales il se
fait déjà le partenariat avec les
missions locales avec Cap emploi il se
fait déjà donc moi j'aimerais que vous
nous disiez qu'elle est l'objectif réel
de ce texte pour ce qui est du RSA vous
avez parlé de contrat d'engagement
réciproque ça se fait déjà
d'inscrire dans le contrat d'engagement
la recherche d'emploi le logement ça se
fait déjà en tout cas dans mon
département c'est ce que nous pratiquons
et je suis certaine que c'est le cas
ailleurs donc là aussi je voudrais
savoir où est la plus-value de ce texte
je voudrais savoir aussi ce que vous
appelez une offre raisonnable d'emploi
et la subjectivité de l'offre
raisonnable d'emploi est-ce qu'elle ne
vous souhaite pas aux yeux les chiffres
des bénéficiaires du RSA qui ne baisse
pas pour un certain pour ceux qui sont
inscrits depuis longtemps nous les
partageons ça veut bien dire aussi et je
sais que là je suis très minoritaire
dans mes propos y compris dans mon
département
il y a une un certain nombre de
personnes que l'on ne pourra jamais
intégrer sur ce que l'on appelle
l'emploi durable donc plutôt que
d'imaginer qu'il suffit de tous les
faire inscrire à Pôle emploi pour qu'il
trouve tout un emploi et et qu'ils
pourvoient les emplois n'ont pourvu
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on n'est pas
aussi en devoir et je dis bien en devoir
parce que nous avons des droits mais
nous avons aussi des devoirs ou même
est-ce que nous ne sommes pas en devoir
de trouver pour ces personnes là des
capacités de sortie autre que sur
l'emploi que nous connaissons mais sur
l'emploi aidé sur enfin tout un tas de
choses aujourd'hui qui leur permettrait
de retrouver une certaine dignité tout
en ne les
autre chose quid du non recours cuit du
nom recours moi je suis atterrée je
pense que je suis pas la seule et je
m'excuse de parler à la première
personne je sais que nous que d'autres
sont concernés mais je préside toujours
une fois par mois une commission
pluridisciplinaire où je reçois des
bénéficiaires du RSA qui ne remplissent
pas qui ne respecte pas leur contrat
l'objectif est de savoir pourquoi il ne
le respecte pas et souvent nous avons
des gens qui ne répondent pas ils ne
viennent pas ils ne s'excuse pas et on
sait pas pourquoi et une fois je vais
vous le raconter je vais vous raconter
ce qui m'est arrivé une personne qui ne
répondait pas pas de nouvelles elle
répondait pas à nos convocations elle
répondait pas au coup de téléphone et
répondez pas trois mois après j'ai été
appelé ça se passait chez moi dans un
logement HLM on l'a trouvé des CD ça
faisait trois mois qu'elle était décédée
elle avait aucun entourage personne ne
le savait et depuis alors c'est un fait
divers je suis désolé mais depuis je
fais vite depuis je refuse de
catégoriquement qu'on laisse sans
réponse quelqu'un qui ne vient pas nous
voir qui et on essaie d'aller toquer à
la porte ainsi de suite mais comment on
fait pour ces gens-là comment fait-on il
faut que il faut nous proposer d'autres
choses sur les conjoints enfin les les
personnes qui vivent avec que l'on
inscrit il y a le RSA couple donc je
vois pas très bien où est la différence
là aussi et dernière dernière monsieur
le Président je termine quand tout le
monde sera inscrit à Pôle emploi qui va
décider comment on va décider de
partager ceux qui sont réellement prêts
à l'emploi et qui sont quand même très
peu nombreux et ceux qui ont
impérativement besoin de la campagnement
social merci
Madame
merci d'avoir obligatoirement rapidement
tout d'abord quand même une remarque
monsieur le ministre ça serait bien que
peu près la réforme des retraites où
vous avez beaucoup parlé du rapport
démographique que vous ne louiez pas la
baisse du chômage simplement à votre
politique d'emploi mais que vous fassiez
la part avec les faits démographique ça
serait plus honnête mais là nous parlons
d'autres choses donc je vais essayer de
voir les questions qui me restent le
temps de moi j'aimerais savoir comment
avec un pilotage par les résultats donc
je sais pas les les indicateurs si ça
sera des indicateurs de processus ou des
indicateurs de résultats mais vous vous
confirmez un pilotage par les résultats
j'aimerais savoir comment vous comptez
maîtriser l'effet d'exclusion sociale
qui est inhérente un pilotage par les
résultats et notamment quand des groupes
privés devront faire et bien ils
prendront dans la file d'attente ils
prendront ceux qui leur donneront les
meilleurs résultats donc il y a toujours
un effet d'exclusion sociale est-ce que
vous croyez que pour ce domaine c'est
tout à fait pertinent de piloter par les
résultats moi ce que j'aimerais savoir
aussi c'est ce qu'a dit René Paul Savary
c'est que effectivement on se dit à
pleine emploi ils vont inscrire tout le
monde donc il y aura plus
l'ortho va monter c'est bizarre parce
que c'est c'est ce sur quoi il s'appuie
le taux de chômage
tous les jours j'aimerais savoir est-ce
que vous comptez oui ou non modifier les
catégories d'emplois
enfin qu'effectivement c'est afflux ne
se traduise pas dans votre communication
sur le taux d'emploi ensuite on a parlé
de la gouvernance de la place des
collectivités territoriales moi
j'aimerais savoir dans cette gouvernance
aux quatre niveaux que vous avez défini
la place des partenaires sociaux parce
que vous en avez parlé pour le national
le rapport de préfiguration on parle
pour le régional mais dans votre loi il
y a rien donc quelle place pour les
partenaires sociaux dit aussi dans cette
loi
pour terminer oui merci vrai que dans ce
cas-là faudrait mieux maîtriser les
prises de parole pour que tout le monde
puisse parler donc je termine quand même
sur le système
d'information vous avez Informatique
vous avez dit qu'il était horizontal
est-ce qu'on doit comprendre que ce que
vous acheminez vers une plate un système
d'information plateforme avec
interopérabilité
plutôt qu'un système d'information
commun qui effectivement ne respectera
pas les spécificités de Cap emploi et de
la Mission Locale merci pour ton numéro
Jacquemet
président merci Monsieur le Ministre
j'ai trois questions à vous poser déjà
concernant le contrat d'engagement
réciproque devront signer les
bénéficiaires du RSA on voit bien la
difficulté qu'il y a les faire signer
dans nos départements en tout cas dans
le département du Doubs on arrive
difficilement à 60 à 65% alors qu'on s'y
attelle depuis des années est-ce que
vous prévoyez des actions de formation
pour les travailleurs sociaux pour
vraiment les focaliser sur ce contrat
d'engagement réciproque la deuxième
question concerne les Mylos que j'ai
rencontrés il y a une quinzaine de jours
dans mon département et qui m'ont
fermenter un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes alors j'ai bien entendu
que vous disiez que rien ne modifier les
missions locales qui continueraient à
voir les 70% de financement de l'État
mais ils ont une grosse inquiétude
concernant leur gouvernance pour savoir
s'ils vont être uniquement qu'on est un
rôle de prestataire puisque j'ai vu
qu'il devrait signer des sépums avec
avec l'État et qui voilà et qui seront
pas forcément considérés comme des
partenaires sur le territoire et puis de
même que mon collègue Savary parlait des
bénéficiaires du RSA qui pour certains
peuvent être inscrits à France travail
pour d'autres sont trop éloignés de
l'emploi dans les missions locales
finalement on a un peu la même
problématique c'est qu'il y a un certain
nombre qui sont en capacité de signer
des contrats d'engagement jeunes mais
d'autres sont trop éloignés et puis pour
lesquels c'est trop coercitif donc les
milots arrivent à attirer ces jeunes là
en étant dans un cadre un peu plus
souple est-ce que ça va continuer à
exister et la troisième chose c'est sur
les systèmes d'information partagée on a
auditionné ce matin la Cour des comptes
qui nous disait bien que dans le domaine
de la santé ça mettait parfois des
années jusqu'à 20 ans être mis en place
on est tous conscients que pour la
notion de parcours qui est indispensable
ces systèmes d'information partagée soit
indispensables aussi alors est-ce qu'il
y a une date maximum qui est prévu
[Musique]
comment dire madame la sénatrice qu'on
est bien sur des un système plateforme
et de l'interrobert de
l'interopérabilité et que des
rapprochements ont déjà été faits c'est
le cas entre Pôle emploi et et Cap
emploi sur la question de
l'employabilité d'abord trois points de
réponse le premier pour dire que la loi
prévoit que pour les allocataires du RSA
les plus éloignés de l'emploi il n'y ait
pas d'orientation dites professionnelles
mais simplement une orientation sociale
avec un point de situation tous les 6 à
12 mois de manière accompagnée dans une
première phase qui ne serait que sociale
avant d'aller vers l'emploi parce que on
sait que ça n'est pas possible la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut aller
chercher les publics madame Lubin a
évoqué l'article 6 reconnaît et intègre
dans le réseau des acteurs de l'emploi
des réseaux France travail les
structures associatives qui font
aujourd'hui de la détection notamment de
la détection publique invisible et qui
font l'intermédiation parce qu'on sait
que c'est nécessaire et excès utile il y
a des choses comme des expérimentations
qui sont menées comme convergence sève
première heure en chantier avec Emmaüs
défi qui sont assez efficaces même
redoutablement efficace sur lesquels on
gagne à s'appuyer et puis la troisième
chose mais ça c'est un débat pour plus
tard si je puis dire c'est qu'est-ce que
nous ferons collectivement le jour où
nous aurons atteint le plein emploi et
le jour où constaterons que ceux qui
restent bénéficiaires du RSA le
locataire du RSA sont justement dans une
situation l'employabilité n'est pas là
et n'est pas possible parce que leur
parcours de vie a été trop accidenté et
je pense qu'on aura je dis que c'est
plus tard parce que nous sommes pas
encore une réflexion collective à avoir
sur la nature des allocations qui
peuvent être versées à des personnes
comme celle-ci en tout cas assumer le
fait que ça ne relève pas d'un revenu
d'activité ou d'un revenu d'insertion
mais peut-être d'autres choses et ça
fait peut-être aussi le lien avec des
problématiques parfois de santé mentale
qui sont redoutables à affronter parce
que dire à un allocataire qu'il ne
pourra pas travailler qu'il n'est pas
capable de travailler c'est aussi une
forme de violence mais ça ça vient
peut-être un peu après en termes de
temps et de chronologie du débats sur la
question du taux de chômage le taux de
chômage est calculé et il fait il sert
de d'indicateurs en France depuis plus
de vingt ans comme cela les calculs sur
la base des critères du Bureau
international du Travail et non pas sur
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
inscrits en fin de mois chez Pôle Emploi
donc l'augmentation des DFM de Pôle
emploi ne se traduit pas mécaniquement
par une augmentation du taux de chômage
par contre ça doit nous inviter et ça ne
laisse pas du gouvernement mais d'une
autorité statistique indépendante à
réfléchir sur non pas les catégories
d'emploi mais les catégories de
demandeurs d'emploi en acceptant
peut-être aussi que certains de certains
inscrits auprès de Pôle Emploi puisse
être parce qu'ils sont dans une session
particulière vous demandez le RSA à 7
mois de grossesse on ne va pas vous
demander d'aller travailler vous
demandez le RSA avec un problème de
santé lourd on ne va pas vous demander
d'aller travailler et donc accepter
qu'il y ait des d e FM qui ne soient pas
soumis astreint à la recherche active
d'emploi mais simplement inscrit dans le
réseau pour bénéficier de
l'accompagnement professionnel pour
quand ça sera possible et nécessaire sur
les missions locales pas de changement
de gouvernance madame Jacquemet associe
participation au comité local France
travail donc association à l'écriture
des orientations ce qui n'est pas
possible aujourd'hui maintien du
conventionnement avec l'État et
d'ailleurs nous avons eu pour dire les
choses très directement nous avons eu
beaucoup beaucoup de concertations avec
l'Union nationale émission locale
parfois même des débats un peu vifs et à
la fin des fins quand le projet a été
présenté au Conseil des ministres l'UML
a indiqué que le texte tel qu'on
présente lui convient et que les
modifications qu'elle avait demandé ont
été apportées de la même manière que la
DF a eu le même type de position pour
les départements de France quand au
texte que l'on que l'on présente
dernier point monsieur le Président je
n'aurais pas été exhaustif mais le débat
nous permettra d'y revenir sur la
question de l'offre raisonnable d'emploi
qui a été évoqué par Madame Lubin je
crois c'est le concept législatif de
2008 dont on sait qu'il ne marche pas
puisque aujourd'hui est-ce que vous êtes
demandeur d'emploi que vous refusez deux
fois une offre dite raisonnable d'emploi
vous êtes menacé de radiation c'est 200
radiations par an à l'échelle de Pôle
Emploi ça n'existe pas l'objectif est
que dans le contrat d'engagement
réciproque on puisse déterminer entre la
locataire et les conseillers en
insertion professionnelle la nature des
emplois le type d'emploi recherché pour
que l'offre raisonnable d'emploi soit en
réalité adaptée au parcours de la
personne et non pas une espèce de notion
un peu conceptuelle comme c'est le cas
dans son application aujourd'hui
nous allons rater la doc la commission
qu'on a les séances des questions à 15
heures merci beaucoup puis nous
continuerons séances ce débat merci